Minnesota has just decided to legalize
abortion
at any point in pregnancy according to
Minnesota quote every individual who
becomes pregnant has a fundamental right
to continue the pregnancy and give birth
or obtain an abortion and to make
autonomous decisions about how to
exercise this fundamental right this is
the protect reproductive options act
every Democrat in the Minnesota state
house voted for this and every
Republican opposed it and the governor
whose Democrat says he'll sign it into
law this now means that Minnesota is in
the same league as North Korea and
communist China when it comes to
abortion much much more radical than
pretty much every other country on Earth
other than North Korea China and Canada
Canada actually is also also there as
well